was kinda rough i had an awful battle
the doctor set my parents down and said
my life was fragile perspective is the
game
i guarantee the name just put your head
down do the work and everything will
change
sympathy helping fields yeah that's what
i wanted be a patient hello
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
vayner nation it is july 1st
a beautiful day i hope everybody has the
best best july
of their entire life it's been a very
intriguing 20
20 but uh yesterday brought me so much
hope what an incredible episode of tea
with garyvee big shout out to alexis
and to dustin dustin uh the post we put
up on instagram
if everybody's watching that full alexis
interview is on instagram right now i
just posted a new announcement
literally just posted while we were
doing the preview my latest post on
instagram
a little bit of a fun announcement but
um the prior post
is the entire interview with uh with
alexis but it ends with
something pretty interesting which is
dustin yesterday we ended with an
emotional moment with me and you
about saying you're sorry taking
accountability and you went out and did
it
updates for everybody who's continuing
the show process um
so i right after the like i did i felt
like i
needed to right after the show so i just
did that use the momentum using the
momentum
yeah and um reached out
uh didn't hear from any of them
initially
for like an hour um then got back and
my one friend said like thanks for
reaching out and
like his family's doing all good and
stuff and
i just apologized again and he said it's
not even a big deal so
don't worry about it and um the other
one
pretty much said uh he he like took some
blame too and
yeah so i thought that was awesome
because i didn't think he would
like he just like the last conversation
we had it didn't seem like
that and when was the last conversation
maybe like three years ago
a lot of changes in three years brother
yeah a lot of growth
yeah and then the one didn't respond but
then he got to me later
yeah yeah and third one did too yeah he
just said thanks for reaching out
it's all good that's it and the one that
i the one that i brought up yesterday
uh the one that it did like last week
he he got back to me too and um he said
it's all good too so
it just shows how like i don't know i
was over like do you feel do you like
just legitimately feel different today
yeah like a weight it's completely off
my
chest like just feels a lot more because
i guess that
like the biggest reason is just because
i'm i just had a lot of anxiety
like going to like events where like i
might see
run into them and just being like all
awkward awkwardness of not knowing what
to do
i basically live my life because i don't
want to run into somebody and have a
negative
vibe in the air it just doesn't have any
value yeah
yes it was incredible thank you dustin
yesterday was incredible if you didn't
watch the episodes
it is on youtube if you didn't see the
alexis interview that led to the dustin
last couple of minutes it is uh my
second to last
post right now on uh on instagram
um and uh and let's get into today's
show
sarah hello hello
wow i've been i've been trying to ask
this question of you for about two years
and i've been following you for just the
longest time and
i just want to say that i know legacy is
really important to you
and um i don't think that you could ever
really understand
like down in the weeds what it does for
people day to day
it's like i'm 56 i mean that kid you
know
he's just he's a little boy and he's all
worried about everything i'm 56 i
shouldn't be asking anyone for
permission to do things but when i do
it's you i come to you and you give me
the permission to do stuff
thank you sarah where do you live you're
very sweet
wyoming montana out in the middle of
nowhere i love it
i can't believe that literally literally
my dad brought up montana
this last week being intrigued and maybe
wanting to go there and just live in the
middle of nowhere so
i mean not really but he was intrigued
we literally were talking about montana
for like 25 minutes
he was asking me about it like do i know
it and things that it was a really funny
conversation he just loves the outdoors
and
the old country and things of that
nature so anyway nonetheless yes sarah
what can i help you if he wants to come
out here
what i do is native american tourism
send him my way i'll take him all over
the place
i will take him out thank you dustin
save sarah's input all right sarah yeah
okay so what i do it's it's native
american tourism and it's a tiny niche
and it's like cultural tourism is like
82 billion
a billion dollar industry and it's
something i think it's 700 billion
dollars in
in cultural in and tourism generally
that's how much you know americans spend
on
um on going on vacations every year but
i can't make my business much bigger
without a wider recognition
for native american tourism because it's
not a thing you know people don't even
know it
exists so part of what i want to do
is um i want to create a brand that
brings everybody together because native
american tourism it's all tiny little
operators here and there
and everybody's struggling everybody's
small people are working in places where
the internet isn't great and all that
kind of stuff so
what i want to do is i want to i want to
dump my business i want to give it to
somebody else let them run it and i want
to
set up something that's like a native
american expedia
and so all the back office stuff
are you are you are you prepared to be
in the technology business
um because it's a very this is where
i'm sort of interrupt this is where it's
very powerful
a lot of people in the last 20 years
i've sat with
that see the opportunity and want to do
the tech thing
the expedia the google the facebook of
and i always ask this question very
aggressively because
it's it's a very real opportunity
but if you do not have a technical
co-founder
the ambition is too big you can't
outsource this you can't have somebody
build this
if you're truly talking about what you
just said you're you're now 100
in the technology business and there's a
lot of people watching right now
who've got an idea for an app and they
want to hire
and they go and like find a team to
build it in india or
poland or belarus or and or an american
app company
and then it always fails because they're
not in the technology business apple
makes an update there's a change on
google like
the site's broken like if you're gonna
build a technology company
you have to ha and you're not a
technologist a cto a chief technical
officer
you need to 100 have
a partner minimally of a
cto who's got she or he's got a real
percentage of the business and cares
otherwise it will always always always
fail so just keep that part in mind
i totally will i really appreciate you
saying that and
do you think that i can start it though
using one of the like
like the systems that's already there i
mean there's all i mean
yeah there's all kinds of like systems
but you don't think i should
let me rephrase you could no no actually
that's not fair i would say you could
just know that if you're going to go
there
building onto you could probably do that
for a year or two but like you're going
to want to build this
you're going to want to build this and i
just technology businesses are super
hard
right super hard which is great which is
great i just
i'll tell you what my hesitation and
reservations are
i want you to have a technical
co-founder okay
i just have never i just i see it i've
seen it
eighty thousand to z to one to zero
you know that people just get into the
tech business
and don't know anything about tech right
or no not enough to build a technology
platform
right i definitely don't know enough to
do that
and the good news is the good news is
there are a lot of people that do
that would love to that are maybe very
fascinated
what's nice about a niche is a niche
and and here's here's your facebook and
i mean right now
there may be a developer who absolutely
is
fascinated by your niche and wants to do
this with you
because he or she wants 20 15 to 49
of a company 50 percent of company
however you figure it out
and and instead of being a coder at
conde ness or the nfl
wants to take that leap with you now
with remote work
so it but just do not go into this
venture if you're going to do it without
a true partner of some sorts in building
tech
okay got it it's the number one mistake
people do when they go into a technology
business
okay have somebody built an app cheap
never works
right okay so here's here's my
my next question which is kind of like
that one of the things i know about
my business is that um the sawdust
that like the sawdust of the business is
the people who don't travel because
they're really interested in native
america
but they don't for whatever reason
they're not coming out here and
those are the people that i've wanted to
reach for a long time and so
like i'm looking like like here we are
now
and and and like you know virtual is all
all the travel industry's got i mean my
business is leveled i'm done for this
season for definite and i don't know
what's going to happen next season which
is why i'm thinking i need to get on
with this now
but because there's all of those people
who don't travel
and because i've wanted to put something
together for them the thing is
i want to know i'm aching to know what
your hunch is for the travel industry
because i've listened to you over and
over
say you know don't don't be the first in
virtual
um experiences and virtual travel
because the big boys need to do that
first and it's so far away but things
have changed now
no everything's different you still
don't you don't we we've been in covid
for hundreds of days or 100 days plus or
what have you
have has anybody here heard of somebody
sitting in a virtual
glasses for five hours it's not a human
behavior yet
right i agree with you if by the way if
vr
was where social media was in 2006
and this happened oh my god it's why
direct-to-consumer
e-commerce has exploded e-commerce
was far enough along this happens now
we're all buying that way
vr if it was lucky enough as a
technology to have been
to the point where every one of us had a
vr unit in our home but just didn't use
it
it would have completely exploded but
there is still no
consumer examples at scale
of people using vr in a meaningful way
of course there's
cutting-edge technology nerds and and
enthusiasts playing here and there but
even they aren't going at it
super hardcore yet virtual travel
put on i you know go in a room in my
house like a theater or put on a thing
or get the contact lenses
i mean we're talking decades away still
at this point from how i see it
now tomorrow somebody might invent
something just like the iphone was
invented
and i'll be like nope change my mind
this is now ready this is the thing but
right now there's
nothing so
in terms of a virtual i mean then in
that case
i can create tours that are like part
virtual and i send a box to people and
they open the box and there's stuff in
there and
and they can i think yes a box
with with you doing two or three hours
talking about that and being a
subscription
very well very real
okay very real if you're going to worry
about you know
you know next year which is worth
worrying about
it's it's definitely worth standing that
up do you think that's going to go on
for a while what's your hunch on that
on kovid yeah i will not code itself but
i mean like
on on people's willingness to movement
everybody's found zoom
everybody can do everything at home now
no i think they will i think they'll do
more zoom i will
but but there's a lot of things you
still need to go for if you need to go
see some [ __ ]
you know native american [ __ ] in montana
you need to go see it
yeah like it it's still different like
looking at a picture of times square
or a video of times square is different
than being a [ __ ] times square
looking at the grand canyon on tv
so like yeah i mean people people will
adapt i think a lot of us will interact
with people more on video
you know face time face time versus
phone calls up
like enormously all those kind of things
we've learned some communication things
but people want to move around
the reason we have an issue with cobit
is people want to move around
if we were disciplined and just sat you
know like
but people people are people love being
social with each other
so i'm gonna move sarah i love you thank
you
you're welcome bye-bye so sweet let's
keep it moving
hey hey siobhan how are you good how are
you good morning
i'm amazing how are you this is so i'm
like good morning to you
so nervous now where are you from i'm
from canada it's canada day now so i'm
wearing
i love it what part of canada i'm from
ontario originally from mississauga but
right now i live
in the sticks nobody knows what it's
called so it's good
rock and roll um okay so
whoo um brief brief
background two years ago i was diagnosed
with chronic anxiety it does run in the
family but we
also have a history of not being
diagnosed in time for proper care
um there was a whole bunch like going on
with that like my grandmother's sick
she's got dementia we're extremely close
so that was devastating to me at the
time
i wasn't happy where i was like work
wise
ended up quitting my job and um going
traveling for two years
so i lived in australia for a year and i
just came back because of covid
and gained some clarity and
and more i guess self-confidence um so
basically now what i'm doing is i've
just started freelancing and marketing
um and then i've also started my podcast
like four weeks ago so i
or five weeks ago um and
i was supposed to be launching a travel
concierge service
for um traveling to trinidad for
carnival
i don't know if you know anything about
the i do i do okay
um so i've been i've been a couple times
i absolutely love trinidad it's my
favorite country out of the
14 countries that i've been to um
and i got that idea because i just had a
lot of friends asking me about
trinidad and what to do for carnival so
i did organize
one group for this past carnival but
because i was in australia i didn't take
on any more
and so yeah i was supposed to launch
that full full force
this year obviously i'm not going to do
that because they're not even opening
their borders
um but i do still want to do it for uh
2022
carnival so i would launch next year
because you have to plan like a year in
advance
um but i'm i'm kind of struggling with
how to balance
marketing those three things for myself
because i don't want to have like three
different pages
do them all on one page yeah the thing
is like i don't i don't know like i do
freelance marketing for other people and
it's perfectly fine like i i
my client that i have now is a fitness
um is a fitness company in toronto
and you know like that's great it's been
going amazing like she's giving me
referrals
um but when it comes to me i don't
really know like how
i should market those three things
obviously the travel one i have to wait
but are you are you insecure about the
feedback on an individual basis or
you're concerned about blending the
three
i think it's more about blending the
three why
i just i don't know you don't you don't
think it's right somebody told you to
focus on one
let's play let's play we're here to like
[ __ ] tee it up
yeah um well i don't like i don't really
know like how to
market myself as a marketer i know that
sounds really controversial like
contradictory but no no you maybe you
are
um maybe you think it's cheesy
i don't yeah i guess because like i i
started like i came back with the intent
um you know what you know what's funny
good that's right i came up with
in the intent to work at a marketing
agency um to get more experience because
i graduated like two three years ago
and then obviously i was traveling so i
don't have as much experience
and it's really like it's really
competitive yeah you're worried about
being an impostor you're worried about
you know faking it and you you might not
you might be concerned
of marketing yourself as a marketer if
you don't feel like you're there yet
yeah do you believe that is that true
kind of i mean i'm if it's not don't
like i don't you're not making me feel
good i want to know the answers
um i don't like i know that i have a
ways to go
but i know that i i know what i'm
talking about for the things that i do
talk about
so so let's go so what's the problem i
just i don't i
when it comes to things like for me i
don't i don't know if it's like an
insecurity thing or
it's an easy question yes but that's but
that's okay
like that's okay we can like we can hack
at that like
to me the bigger thing is is that's why
i asked you
are you worried about the feedback and
the insecurity on the individual level
or is it worried about the um you know
about the mixing of the three and you
went with the mixing of the three but
it's probably just the insecurity of the
overall thing
sure no um i guess i guess
to a degree like i maybe a mix maybe
like
thirty percent of one and forty percent
of the other yeah it's kind of like
it's a bit of it's a bit of both like i
don't know
listen here's the biggest thing yeah
none of it matters
sure like once everybody realized
my favorite thing to do and i've got a
lot going on
and when i'm in my most like laying in
bed like concerned about something i
literally go to a place of like nobody
gives a [ __ ] about me who gives a [ __ ]
doesn't matter it's actually a weird
thing
it's actually a very good pour your
water i know you need it like you know
it's
it's not it's coffee
it's a it sounds like an interesting way
to go about it but it's like
it's actually a humility thing not an
insecurity thing like
like you know the answer is that it
doesn't matter right
yeah i guess i have like i'm really good
at making plans
and strategies and whatnot but i guess
like the execution part when it comes to
because yes because you're worried about
what happens after you execute
everyone's great
it's why people love to hide behind
perfection
people like gary you don't get it i'm a
perfectionist that's why i don't post
i'm like you're not a perfectionist
you're scared
you like talking big game but you don't
like for it to be out there because then
it's actually getting judged
you're not comfortable with judgment
is what i say that you know i'm going
kind of macro here not necessarily
what's here
i i think that i think for me what's
what what what i what i'm trying to
figure out especially when as i throw
things out you're like nah
which is amazing what i'm trying to
figure out is
how to get you to understand that forget
about me forget about you
like the only way it actually works out
is by doing like all the answers
that you're trying to figure out within
your own head
in these 13 minutes they're all
irrelevant at some level until you start
to get to the process of doing
only doing gets you to the answer
yeah um i know that too
i guess um i don't i guess it's it's
more so like
in addition with this like the um
executing of
these plans like i'm very indecisive
like so before i got that's
the same thing though you know that
right it's all the same
it's all this you're indecisive you're
like it's all
it's all the same game it's all to not
let you do the [ __ ] thing
she want literally literally the first
25 posts i put out about business
85 percent of the comments were staying
your lane wine boy
literally me where i'm at stay nearly
why boy why you're selling out gary why
are you talking about business you're a
wine guy
like don't talk about [ __ ] you don't
know why
you can't live for feedback okay
um and then that that no it make it
makes you
like you're absolutely right i've been
listening to you for a while so i knew
this was happening
um you know that every every every
characteristic you have
is leading to your fear of the feedback
just a self-esteem it's just a
self-esteem game
yeah you're right it's also
you know it's a you know what's amazing
it's a winnable game
a lot of people a lot of people resign
to the fact of like well my grandma was
like this my mom was like this um like
this like they just kind of resigned to
it
oh with the anxiety you mean yeah just
like all forget about exactly you know
we yes i know you brought up that fact
but i'm just talking in the macro
like like when you sit here and you're
like you're right and
everyone's sitting and thinking about
themselves and saying you're right and i
think about the things that i was
scared of whether it was swimming or
riding a bike or it was fear of those
kind of things
you know it but it's back to swimming
and riding a bike or kissing a boy or
girl
all of it's so scary until you do it and
then you spend all your time
saying to yourself the [ __ ] was i scared
of
so like that's why you love that's why
you love creating for others because
you're good at it but you don't get the
feedback that company does and you're
behind the scenes
that's exactly it i'm aware
by the way by the way there's nothing
wrong
being that kind of operator in business
too
what's what what is what i don't want is
for you to
go that route and never address what
makes you anxious
or concerned about other people's
opinions
you know i often talk about a lot of um
about like don't take positive feedback
too heavy because then negative
feedback gets you right you've been on
i'm reading the comments
you know like lots of like she's so
beautiful she's so beautiful she's so
beautiful like you know
one of the things i talk about a lot is
like you know one thing that you may
want to think about shimon and this is
like the first time i've
say it a lot but i don't talk about it i
haven't had the opportunity on t
to really talk to somebody about it one
of the things for you to really think
about
is not get too high when people give you
compliments
it's really worked for me simon it's
really worked for me
like it's unbelievable to me how it goes
through my chemicals when people are
like you're the goat you're the greatest
you change people live you walk on water
it doesn't get me too high it really
doesn't
which then protects me when people are
like you're the worst you're the one you
know
stays in a pocket okay of course there's
you know
that might be something to think about
that might be something to think about
when
somebody comes at you like you're so
beautiful or you're great at work or
you're amazing or this
was the best trip i've ever been on you
appreciate it
but you don't think you're somebody
which then ironically helps you when
somebody says you're [ __ ] this was the
worst carnival or
i didn't like this video or that post is
stupid or why are you mixing dumb [ __ ]
or your page looks weird it's not
or you know i don't like the way your
instagram looks because it's all over
the place like all of a sudden
you you appreciate the feedback you
understand you listen you respect it
but you don't get you don't think you
suck you think one person has an opinion
then this isn't great
yeah and so like what
i don't what type of content should i
put out for
like the freelancing because i do want
to start taking on
a video a video of you straight to
camera saying hey
i want to take on more clients i'm a
freelance marketer in this video you'll
see some of the stuff i've done
little editing doesn't have to be fancy
post it on linkedin
and instagram and facebook
ask ask
okay and then should i do that same
thing for
like tick tock two hell yeah
i'm struggling on tick tock listen
struck you're not struggling on tick
tock you haven't found it yet
yeah that's true i have been trying like
different types of content to see like
how many persons
um i don't know maybe
30 40. just not enough i'm gonna
[Music]
um actually more than that does it tell
you how many if you haven't done it
you struggled at walking the first 18
months of your life
just early girl it's just [ __ ] early
okay um and what are you what are your
thoughts actually no i don't want to
take any more time from anybody else
i'm good yeah thank you are you what did
you get from this
um not to let good or negative comments
get to me
is that did that one hit you
um does that make sense to you like yeah
it does basically i'm basically trying
to figure out why you're scared to post
something
i think it's just like the overall and
like anxiety of it
um but because i decided to become good
i went from like before i went traveling
i was
i wanted to be in the fitness industry
so like my whole page was all fitness
and i had
i had classes i had clients like i was
doing really good and then
when i was kind of going through all of
that like my grandmother was diagnosed
and i was diagnosed
um like i was just kind of like confused
because i
i took your advice and i went out and
like i was offering people free classes
and i was i messaged like 100
um different like fitness influencers on
instagram a couple of them responded one
of them actually like
gave me his number so i could call and
ask him questions about it like about
the industry
he's like yeah like we have this group
in toronto if you want to come and like
learn some tips i
feel free um but like talking to these
people i've realized like i didn't have
the passion that they had
for fitness like i i liked fitness and
like i
liked helping i liked helping and that
was the thing i like helping people
no matter what it is and so that's why i
kind of thought that it was amazing
yeah um and so i kind of i guess
i went from that and then had a mental
breakdown and i went traveling and now i
like
people ask me still they're like oh like
you don't work out anymore i'm like no
not really
like um i just kind of like go for walks
and backpacks
that's good someone listen to me
this you have to spend every second of
your life every second of your life
not valuing other people's opinions
about your life
ready we're going to role-play you're
johnny magoo siobhan
i'm going to be shimon like johnny magu
what's up sivan you're not working out
anymore no are you
like that's it he's like yeah i'm like
but then like he's like i'm crushing i'm
like and how's your this and how's your
relationship with your dad like
everybody's got something
do not do not value other people's
opinions respect them
understand it think it but
it doesn't [ __ ] matter when you're 92
you're not gonna give a [ __ ] about the
random person that asked you who worked
out
in [ __ ] 2020 promise
go up other people's opinions
period you're right i know but start
practicing you know how when you were
working out
it was reps every day
every day
my aunt's in the background hi auntie
that's it got it yeah
hit me up if you need me in the future
thank you
bye
look these things are not fixed in 17
minutes with me on a [ __ ]
youtube show you know like this is real
[ __ ] but the themes
matter and they matter to a lot of you
so let's keep it moving
oh my god what's up adam and danny
i'm adam this is danny how's it going
again danny zabaleta
um i want to thank you for the
opportunity this is an honor for me to
be here man this is a dream of mine
before we get started to the question i
want to share some of the story of how
you influenced me and i followed your
advice
uh before i got into this career field
uh i love your philosophy about mindset
self-awareness doubling down in your
strengths um
that's exactly what i did in order to
get into this field being brand new
without having any knowledge i met with
adam
and i said to him i don't have any
knowledge of the field but i know i
wanted to get into something
different uh and i'm willing to work for
free and
uh i entered from well i was bartending
at the time
and i you know interned for like three
months or so working for free
learning the process being patient and i
want to thank you for that
it helped me a ton so i really do
appreciate that
and let me say something off of that
danny like for everybody's watching
being patient the process three months
is nothing
shout out to adam for like that's
nothing like
by the way for you listen let me let me
rephrase that 90 days going hard working
for free is something
it's actually remarkable but like [ __ ]
if you want to be happy
people are talking about happiness out
here if you want to be happy
[ __ ] three years if you want to be
happy right like so anyway nonetheless
that's fantastic that you did that and
it's fantastic on the flip side
that you didn't have to do it for so
long either for sure
so danny's been with us for a year so
dana and i represent a home care agency
here in naples florida
um i don't know if you know much about
home care but typically in simple terms
we help
you know the asian population agent
plates at their homes
um so looking back at what you did in
the 90s of
disrupting the wine industry if you how
do you disrupt an industry
that's so traditionally tried and true
like home care
by building reputation on facebook
because everybody who's 50 to 90 lives
on facebook
for sure i'd [ __ ] live on facebook
for sure for sure so
obviously right now traditionally real
quick hold on one second
i got a comment here from sean thomas i
tried to work for free got turned out
once sean do it another 90 times
keep going so obviously coronavirus has
played a
huge impact in our day-to-day you know
typically on a regular week we're in the
hospitals rehabs this is the living he's
doing sales calls
um so we have shifted to you know really
doubling down on social media digital
marketing
facebook being on facebook right so
right and that's why i want to kind of
that's that's my
question is facebook's our main platform
and we've dived into
linkedin i think helpful
so now how many posts a day and how many
yeah fake bro straight up if i was the
third partner
we would probably post on facebook in
the 40-mile radius of naples florida
25 times a day while running a hundred
different ads with 30 to 40 dollars per
ad against them
if we can afford it okay okay
we would start a facebook group
yep let me just say it one more time
30 40 50 60 pieces of content a day
i'd go live for an hour a day
i would ask our favorite home care you
know clients if they want to do facebook
with us
for some of them that's going to bring
them joy and happiness
right for for us that's a testimonial
from a real [ __ ] person
all of a sudden you're tried as true as
[ __ ] when they see gertrude saying
you're the best
so you say like i know you've said
double down on tick tock do you think
tik tok is not appropriate for home care
let me tell you why if you said to me
you were posting 60 times a day
on facebook and you had more bandwidth
then i'd be like okay let's strategize
about the granddaughters becoming
you're not even a [ __ ] game on the
thing that you have to do 80 percent of
your energy against
when i talk about do everything you know
that's right in the macro the reason i
do tea with garyvee is
now i'm hearing your exact business and
your
exact business needs to [ __ ] go hammy
ham ham ham ham
for sure for sure now don't now do you
think like linkedin would
be a good avenue for like referral
sources like
i think i think i think you're being
theoretical
which is fantastic you know like
you're trying to be thoughtful and
theoretical but your [ __ ] ass needs
to get serious about facebook bro
yeah i'm looking for 60 pieces of
content a day i'm looking for
like look i'm looking for a [ __ ] hour
on facebook live i'm looking for you to
reach out to all your clients and ask
them if they want to do facebook live
you have work to do
don't talk to me about any other [ __ ]
app yeah
we we're doing segments on on facebook
actually we're doing like a three or
three so we're bringing on like referral
partners and community resources so
we're doing stuff not to the volume that
you're probably saying so which you can
do
how many pieces of content do you put
out every day on facebook organically
in a facebook group or running an ad
against it flat out
two to maybe two yeah
you're 100 years away from the
opportunity now and
when we're talking about content i mean
there's so many different avenues you
can go like for
me i want people to understand the
purpose like why do i get my hands
ready for this ready for to set them
when you're doing 60 a day everything
out of your little [ __ ] beautiful
head is going to be able to be done
i don't give a [ __ ] of everything that
you're about to say all of it's going to
be yes
why i get up in the morning gertrude's
[ __ ] journey
things that people aren't thinking about
why alexa is good for
grandparents like all of it
that's what's amazing about 60. i don't
have to debate which [ __ ] post
for sure for sure
crazy all right well yeah just that
means investing in time
push push push of course the time but
we're trying to build a business out
here what the [ __ ] are we doing
yeah danny
listen to me danny 60 [ __ ] pieces of
content today you know how much work
that is
it's a lot it's a ton you got to design
some pictures you got to go take some
photos you got to go interview people
you got to get
like but i really like using your
current clients if they're into it i'll
tell you why
they're going to like it not mo some are
private as [ __ ]
right some are embarrassed that they're
90 now like there's a million different
things
but there's some people that this
they're lonely
and doing this content with you will
bring you happiness do you think that's
a big enough differentiator because
there's other home care agencies which i
i applause i mean listen i'm not afraid
of competition
but there's a lot of people are trying
to to do this doesn't matter what
competition
yeah and i'm playing basketball every
day and
i'm not [ __ ] lebron james right
there's a hundred
you know how many [ __ ] gary v
wannabes there are right now
and guess what right now there's 13 year
old sarah d
and she's gonna come along and beat my
ass and become number one
it's all merit i don't give a [ __ ] how
many people are in the game
who's best right for sure
i don't [ __ ] second on any of those
people
zero worry about the consumer don't make
sure everyone who's watching right now
follows us on facebook so we can
continue to put out good content
[ __ ] everybody here unless they've got
you know elderly in naples
hit them up worry about focusing on 20
30 40
ads per piece of content in the greater
naples area
you will be stunned what will happen
to hear another yeah mind-blowing thing
fast
yesterday alexis your last guest
great content i was his eighth grade
teacher
what [ __ ] you
bro what is the chances like i was in
queue i was like two more to go i'm like
wait
i taught that kid crazy he's such a good
guy like such a good kid
mind-blowing and was he did he struggle
you know he talked a lot about struggles
like like he was a great kid but he had
all these [ __ ] feelings and it
manifested in some like
crazy [ __ ] so i rewatched it last night
and i was like
now i'm trying to recall i mean before i
got into healthcare i taught in public
school at north naples middle school
and i'm like i remember him distinctly
like i remember like he was such
like i really knew he was like deep down
inside he's like really good kid
just had to find his path you know so
adam you literally literally the hair
off my i almost have the same haircut as
do like you're literally blowing my
[ __ ] mind
that is like that is unbelievable
yeah i mean even just two people from
naples being on the same show but like
literally i taught him crazy
facebook watches watch this
see ya thank you
dustin yep
yeah i remember uh adam brought it up
yesterday in the private chat
and then i was hoping you would sing and
make it yeah everybody if you haven't
figured out we're taking it to a new
level here
please share this right now please hit
the share button if you're watching live
on twitter
or linkedin or facebook please if not
can you grab the url okay like let's get
more people in this community i think
there's so much good going on here it's
gonna help people
please please please please please
please please share dustin do we
do we we don't schedule like does
youtube's like
how do we end the show where we already
have a url for tomorrow's show that
gives
the vayner nation here the ability to
like get more like do we have an rsvp
for youtube i know we went away from
that on facebook because it does better
if we just go live
like where are we at with that um we can
do that
like i could set up two like
events at the same time like today and
then tomorrow and the next day i could
just keep doing it like i could set them
all up but
i mean i just want to set up youtube
because i think
you know because that doesn't affect the
it seems like on facebook it affects the
reach
if you schedule it versus going live
yeah why don't you set up tomorrow's
youtube or have a team right now do that
and at the end
let them have a gary let them make a
garyvee url so it's easy for everybody
to
you know like t72 for july 2nd or
something you know what i mean
yeah and then throw it up here like that
and then last three minutes we should
just have everybody like share it in the
comments people control copy it paste it
like save it to promote it for tomorrow
like we just need like i feel like
i feel like we're up to something really
good
and i feel like i want to get crazy on
momentum okay
all right cool please team and let's
make this
like if you're part of the let's create
like a shared squad like
share squad like every time you come on
at nine like you go right into sharing
right away
like we like the this ten thousand
collective people
should get the next ten thousand like
there's something very real going on
here let's move it
if you share use hashtag shared squad
cameron what's good
what's going on gary how you doing i'm
doing well it's really nice to see you
nice to meet you man uh so i'm a little
terrified to be honest because
you're one of my heroes and i've been
looking up to you for a long time
um very sweet thank you i'm trying to
get everything together here so
i've been working in i.t for about 10
years now
and over the last year or so
my career has changed tremendously
because i've gained a lot more
responsibility
so my uh jobs become more stressful
in that time about two years ago i
started a podcast called origin
mysteries
and i was having a ton of fun with it
but because
my job has become so stressful
and also me and my wife just had our
first child congratulations
thank you he's 11 months old so our
lives
have changed tremendously so i'm you
know going into work grinding at my
regular job
coming home and you know trying to make
sure my wife is okay
because she's been with the baby this
whole time and i want to support her and
then
but i also want to do the podcast too
because people
seem to like it but it's also one of
those deals where
i've been doing it for two years now and
it seems like my listenership has stayed
the same so
do you enjoy doing it i do
is it an escape so look at it as a hobby
instead of the thing that's going to
change
your business life you're doing it for
you it's no different than you playing
video games
you're listening to music like people
need to blow off steam
i literally buy and sell sports cards to
blow off steam
okay you know you know like like i think
you're doing it
to instead of watching a netflix series
you're doing it for happiness you need
it to balance all the other chaos
it doesn't have to become [ __ ] the
joe rogan show it's there for cameron to
be happy
okay that i haven't really looked at it
that way it seemed i think by the way
by the way i'm sorry to interrupt that's
the whole point of this [ __ ] show
this
whole game of life is about [ __ ]
perspective
of the way we look at things
think about it all of a sudden all of a
sudden when you say to your wife
and she's like huh you know you know
connie i need this the way some people
the way you watch this tv show or listen
to that podca
it's it's therapeutic for you it's
fantastic
and by the way i was as happy when i had
nine people watching wine library tv me
and that little crew
were [ __ ] family it brought me as
much joy as i have now with millions i'm
being dead [ __ ] serious
that's not me being humble i'm being
dead [ __ ] serious
i i i've never looked at it that way so
that's thank you for that
the only problem that i run into is
and i think i've kind of looked at it
i've tried to kind of market it as an
escape for other people
and when that happens uh and yeah i
agree
the only problem is is that kind of like
a lot of people
have been on your show said i get in my
head because i wanted to be perfect
because i want
the person's like drive to work that
morning to be about
you're not a great camera you're not in
charge of that
okay watch this cameron uh i don't know
what
platform you're watching but i'm gonna
watch the comments uh everybody in the
comments right now all the platforms
twitch big shout out to twitch i love
what's going on there i need some share
community in there
um how many people here the first time
they saw my content
thought i was a piece of [ __ ] bad guy
one of those scummy
scummy guys cam how did you first see me
was was that
was it good or was it like oh this guy's
probably got some angle
tell the truth it's okay i'll be honest
with you i've never seen anybody do
the content that you were doing at that
time and i was like this guy
is next level because just because you
kept it real
and that's what i try to do so ready i
apologize kim like a lot of people a lot
of people being very sweet not me and i
appreciate that but some people yeah
buddy like
you know scummy guy dustin big shout out
to you for saying like
what i'm why i brought that up is i'm
not in control
of how they saw me
got it there is no product there's only
cameron
okay you i would argue the more you
think about it the more likely it won't
land
well it's yeah because it's not i'm too
afraid honestly i'm too afraid to post
content
yeah because you're insecure about the
feedback
yeah i think that's what it is because
i'll sit here and record
and then i'll just stop because i'm like
you know no one's gonna listen to this
camera one person listening to it and
liking it is worth it
all right yeah you're right you're right
so should for because i know a lot of
people like to see
big shout out to everybody with the love
first sight crew love at first sight
i love you [ __ ] thank you for that
i'm flattered go ahead brother
so how how could i like share more of
this content to like
instagram because i would like to
i haven't figured out a way because i
see all the other podcasters and they're
a lot of them that i follow are just
kind of having a conversation and again
it kind of gets into my head where it's
like
no one wants to see me just sitting
there reading
but first of all brother
you're doing it for yourself
bro if you had one super fan you're good
okay being dead serious bro
so let me let me ask you this because i
think honestly i feel like it's
added more pressure to me because i was
talking to my wife because we were
both freaking out about being on this
show so thank you again for putting me
on here
but i have a patreon that i started
about a year ago
should i just close that down because it
almost feels like that weighs on me more
yes but what about the people because
i've had like a solid
seven or so people support me through
this entire year of being on the patreon
what if i close it i mean are they gonna
like hate me no you put them into a zoom
group and you hang out with them and
have a beer or coffee or a glass of wine
once a week and just shoot the [ __ ]
become a family
okay they're gonna love you more
and you're gonna make some friends and
you're gonna love them more
and it'll come full circle and i'll
actually enjoy it instead of
panic when i'm doing it
okay that's what i'll do then i'll do it
today hobbies
are amazing
what if um for something like this
to because i enjoy it as a hobby
and i enjoy the feedback
so do you think that if i turn the
patreon off and i just start
posting stuff it'll all just come
together
hold on one second looks like facebook
froze i see the comments i don't know
what's going on there
what's up brother so should i just
start posting and don't worry about
anything of course
nobody's watching you anyway okay
is it okay just to stay where i'm at
just keep doing
what i'm doing because you look at
instagram you look at other people and
i'm like
i don't want my instagram to look like
crap because i still want this podcast
to look nice you know what i mean
yes but don't don't forget that nice is
the eye of the beholder
okay
okay is that how you did your first
is that how you did with your podcast
bro did you see the early episodes of
wine library tv was like it looked like
a [ __ ] hostage situation
[Laughter]
okay so just have fun with it and then
it will take the pressure off of it take
the seven people that are paying you out
make a zoom private group that you meet
once a week that's what you're giving
them you're not even charging them
they're gonna become your friends
you're gonna be set
okay can i ask you this yeah
in a couple months maybe like in october
can i follow up with you and tell you
yes how this has changed everything for
me yes yep
okay well i appreciate it man thank you
so much for
everything you've done got you wp man
thank you
have a great day dustin yeah
what's happening on facebook um i think
when i sent the link out it like just
froze
the feed for a sec but i just told
everyone to refresh and it should be
okay
is that true i mean yeah like i went on
my end
like through my personal account and it
seems to be
fine okay it looks like it facebook let
me know if we're good
all right why'd you send the link out
because i thought we were doing the url
on youtube not facebook
in case they want to
convert i see you posted
the youtube link into the yes book
everywhere yeah so the one rsvp we're
gonna have is gonna be for youtube yeah
good awesome let's keep it going let's
think one more in cool
it's all gucci hello he with garyvee
share squad share squad in the video
what's good share it on twitter um hi
gary
um it's a real what's your name my name
is cj
perfect um uh christian
joe vaughn let's go joe bond good [ __ ]
what's good um it's a real honor to talk
to you gary
um i've been consuming your content for
at least three years and i have like
some context and a question just gonna
give it all
um so i love being a recording artist
and if it looks like i'm reading i do
have like some bullet points i'm just
kind of every
half of people read their questions so
i'm used to it don't worry
cool um so yeah i love being a recording
artist and i do want to grow so in the
past three years i have gained like a
small audience by literally
talking to so many of your fans and like
liking them first as you would say
um like back in the day i would have
notifications turned on for a bunch of
youtubers like mainly you
and i i was in digital agency world so i
had a bunch of youtube accounts like
that i had access to
so every time a new video came out i
would rush to my phone go to the
comments section
and i'd be like guys don't worry about
who i am here's all my songs to put in
vlogs if you're a creator reading this
like it wasn't like about me it was a
kind of shady thing but i felt like i
was selling flowers to homeowners
like it was weird but um it kind of
worked i got hundreds of streams like
and just a couple followers and it was
like a small like local snowball
and that would result in some fans
listeners and siege while i'm with you
you know
even though i was five i'm not pumped or
proud about the flower thing
you know you know like doing the right
thing is always the right thing you know
i'm not pumped about the flower thing or
the shack thing like you got to do the
right thing so keep in mind keep going
yeah i totally hear you it was my like
quickest like
i get it resistance um and a lot of
people ended up
taking the music and they used it so i
feel good about like providing sonics
for their stuff for the videos yep for
sure um
and that would result in some fans
listeners and then you know i ended up
meeting jason
very good guy stand up guy on your team
um and he's put my music in some of your
videos
i was in new york city and i got to tour
vayner and it was amazing
um it was a blessing so it's kind of
like a testimonial story of you know
kind of like went from shady tactics in
the beginning and then evolved into like
better practices honestly it's a lot
it's a lot of what i'm trying to do with
my content the last three four years
especially is take
take kids that come from the same place
as i did and say like look
if we're going to be businessmen let's
be honorable men let's be kind men let's
be empathetic men let's be noble men
let's do the right thing
period 100 100 um
you know things from there kind of
compound a little bit i ended up with a
couple million streams on spotify and i
want to scale my awareness so
i've been supporting my passion with
income from operating in the digital
marketing agency space so
managing clients and i learned how
powerful paid facebook and ig is for new
discovery
um and i'm i'm actually a technician
like on the ads like i know how to run
it
and i also know how powerful tic tac is
for discovery so my main question is
i'm also trying to save money because i
live in an apartment with my
girlfriend's parents still
but i've been putting all my money into
ads and stuff like that
and you know best mixing and just
putting into the music
but my main question is like should i
start like rearing back on ads and like
save a thousand a month so so i have
yeah
yeah okay yes yes i think balance
matters
i mean let me let me rephrase the answer
is yes
or maybe no if you and your girlfriend
and your girlfriend's parents
are all about you being there for four
years then i don't mind betting the farm
okay okay but if but if you and your
girl are kind of like
to get in you know go somewhere like
then then
then say listen saving money is always
right
okay always okay period
the biggest do you know many people woke
the [ __ ] up because of covid on that
they got their stimulus checked now
that's gone and we're nowhere close yet
so now what yeah and it's
saving saving money and selling [ __ ]
around the house
is my number one favorite thing you've
been in you've been in this situation
for four years at the parents apartment
yeah and i've been running ads but i
haven't had enough to even have
impactful ads so it's kind of like
spinning my wheels a little bit
listen if you could save a thousand a
month if you were talking that kind of i
mean are you capable of saving a
thousand a month
i can that's huge bro do that do you
have any savings
i've been spending my wheels right now
so like maybe like yeah
no okay three grand in student debt i
left in the first semester
understood um pay off your debt because
it's okay it's got it's got interest
right
yeah yeah get rid of that so like stop
that 2500 you know like
it's gonna be ugly here for a couple
more months yo sell that nike hat
you know put that [ __ ] on [ __ ] you
know poshmark or something
um if you're capable if you're capable
of saving a thousand a month i love you
i think you can have an incredible year
pay off that debt save the thousand a
month that means you can pay off the
debt in three months based on what i'm
hearing
in three months you're out of debt four
months you're out of debt maybe nine
months because you want to keep a little
bit of money for this
like but and [ __ ] save bro
and then when i have something saved now
i'm ahead of my expenses so in case
something happens i can just take what i
was going to dump on ads and save my
life if i needed to or i can just run
ads like in it
okay okay thank you so much and then
that answers that question we need to
make we need to make saving money cool
again
oh yeah i agree i need to make
discipline
a thing in my life too um also i've been
considering some ways to monetize as an
artist outside of streaming in merch
and some creative ideas are maybe like
having fans like invest in my releases
for like a portion of the streaming
royalties
get something like 100 yes okay okay
access
access creating a you know a scenario
where you're
you know doing three hours of teaching
people what you've learned for
you know 50 bucks 100 bucks a month
access okay
this kind of and this is the last thing
i'll tip i'll touch on because you're so
efficient with your answers um
when it comes to that last girl who was
kind of like she was a marketer but she
didn't want to like market all the sides
of herself because it was a little
maybe it was cheese or something like
that i feel that too because
yeah just do whatever i want nerd [ __ ]
you're into like like if you're into
dragon ball z that should be a post
like bro i'm out there [ __ ] garage
sailing and talking about sports cards
okay hell yeah right yeah
i get that you're in the [ __ ] music
industry and all this [ __ ] but like the
most authentic beats the coolest every
time
all right dude 100 percent i'm sorry
a stack of legos versus a stack of cash
is gonna win at the end real
[ __ ] wins bro be you
all right all right see ya later
dustin big day on t with garyvee uh
if you haven't seen already vaynernation
um
i haven't even put i posted on my
instagram i haven't posted on my twitter
yet
but uh this morning we announced the
acquisition of empathy wines
uh we've sold the company to thank you
dustin we've sold the company to
constellation brands the
owners of things like robert mondavi and
simi and some of the biggest brands in
the world corona
beer uh it is a major transaction i want
to thank my parents
john and me my partners it's an
incredible
uh it's an incredible um
quick you know accomplishment
i uh i'm very humbled i think it proves
out
a lot of the capabilities of the vayner
kind of dna and
the execution i want to thank so many of
you here that have
supported empathy we need your continued
support we've got some back end to this
deal so
i need to sell more empathy with
consolation's incredible vineyards and
winemakers we'll be able to
make even a better wine to be frank so
it just uh
just announced it um and uh i'm very
proud
and so it's a big deal a big deal
so thank you so much for that and thank
you for everybody who's watching who
gave it support
and thank you for supporting the show we
have the url if everybody can
grab that url speaking about wine huge
wine text today
get ready for that huge actually one of
the coolest ones but this url really
matters to me garyvee.com
t with gary t with gb0702
please save it everybody can you please
in your own chats right now
put this url so for other people they
can just control copy it
and paste it and maybe you can uh paste
it during the day today and tell
everybody why this is
one of the best hours you spend every
morning means a lot to me
share squad i love you tomorrow morning
we get on
new rule when we get on immediately
share the url in one way or another
to be part of the share squad and leave
a copy leave a comment saying you're
part of the share squad so anyway thank
you so much for all the support on
empathy
it's a big deal big transaction sales in
my career
and um and i'm very grateful thank you
thank you so much thanks for everybody
who's sharing it i see all of you love
you shirley joseph thank you juan garcia
sean thomas thank you
abel v great to see you thank you so
much greenpreneur
thank you melissa lee scoo what's good
master 23 mind thank you so much
vicki j always great to see you luisa
thank you so much
ginger thank you so much jessica oh
thank you so so so much
daisy c shelly m looking forward to
tomorrow
see ya
and the people that are gonna win